well sean ron congratulations your hard
work has paid off and you are both
moving forward in the third and final
round of this competition now at this
point you get to go back to your home
forges for four days using your tools
and your electricity to build this
the sword of mercy
the sword of mercy also known as cortana
has been used as a coronation sword
since the middle ages the ceremonial
blade is defined by its squared blunted
tip legend has it the sword was broken
off by an angel to prevent a wrongful
killing and therefore symbolizes the
mercy it's named for to this day this
benevolent blade is one of the crown
jewels of the united kingdom and is
still in use in coronations of kings and
queens today although even commoners can
see it on display in the jewel house of
the tower of london
so good luck guys
we will see you in four days
my name is sean meadows i am 20 years
old and i am a full-time bladesmith and
woodworker
my mother has lent me one half of her
garage to set my entire workshop up in
as much as i love being able to work in
my mom's garage winning ten thousand
dollars would finally be the ticket that
i need to move out into my own shop i
think this is a solid build of steel
i had this blade forged out to shape and
ready for quench the more normalizing
cycles i have to do on this blade the
more i realize it's gonna be a [ __ ] to
get it all up to temp and ready for
quench i've never had to quench a blade
this big this quench is worrying me more
and more
i'm terrified
there's not much i can do i can't start
over
i'm definitely panicking inside
it's hard the blade is straight this
thing hardened as much as it needed to
which i am relieved to hear dave baker
is very picky about the way things feel
in his hands so i want to make sure this
thing feels phenomenal i want to give
them as little reasons to complain as
possible
looks kind of cool
all that's left is getting everything
together
as long as it holds up i should do well
hell yeah
i'm ron burkland i'm 50 years old i've
been bladesmithing for three years i was
in the military where i spent 18 years
in the national guard i spent four years
active duty so i did 22 years complete
my experiences in the military helped me
feel like i can accomplish anything
i don't have a power hammer or a press
so my biggest challenge is going to be
just getting the shape i want that's
good so as i'm hammering this out i'm
noticing i'm starting to get a crack on
both sides of where i'm shaping this
the biggest issue it's going to have is
on a strength test and more chance of it
breaking i enjoy being able to hand
forge things but i need to start making
some progress
i cut the shape that i roughly need
and it's looking pretty good
on the money okay good so far so good
everything is going right and tight
finally at the finish line it's done i
really like the way it looks
and i think it'll hold out the testing
[Music]
placements welcome to the keel test
run your first you ready for this make
some pork chops
all right ron let's talk about your sort
of mercy here
these are sharp chops
each cut was very deep followed by the
nice weight that's backing up the sword
it cuts deep into this big carcass and
of course as you can see it's easy to
wield and follow through and control
your weapon overall sir your weapon
it'll kill yeah
all right sean your turn are you ready
yes sir let's do this
i'm pretty nervous i know these pics can
be pretty gnarly to blades so i'm just
hoping that mine goes clean through
[Music]
all right sean talk about your sword of
mercy here i'm able to hold on to it i
can tell where the edge is
but your blade sir is not very sharp as
you can see in the first cuts right
there it's more from blunt force trauma
but as you can see with the first six
inches here you have some spots that are
sharp and that sir is what made your
blade
heal
melismas welcome to our strength test
the throne shop
ron you're up first you look excited oh
yeah it's overthrown monarchy let's do
it
all right ron good job edges are still
razor sharp
but that shockwave is traveling all the
way down this blade and
your guard's loose now
but it was comfortable in the hand
good job thank you
hey sean
how you feeling awful
let's hope you feel better in a few
minutes let's hope
um
good job
thank you
all right john it's all in one piece
gotta be proud of that your blade is
still straight this way
not this way
your handle is not loose
but it's definitely separated from the
base of the handle now but like i said
it's still in one piece good job thank
you sir
all right bladesmiths now it's time to
find out just how sharp your weapons are
this is the sharpness test the tapestry
slice
run your first you ready oh yeah let's
make it pretty all right let's do it
hold on
thank you
all right ron first stop
it is loose but it did not affect my
test
overall sir your edge you will cut
awesome
all right sean your turns are you ready
yes sir all right let's do this
all right sean around this area right
here you have some sharp edges so you
can see on the first cut here in this
tapestry it cut in but when i'm dragging
through it just stops its cut
but
it still did cut so
it will cut thank you sir
the bladesmith has been a good
competition right from the very
beginning but as you know only one of
you guys can leave here with the title
of fortune fire champion carrying a
check for ten thousand dollars now our
judges discussed your blades and i'm not
gonna leave you in the dark any longer
today's fortune fire champion is
ron congratulations
now shawn you fought hard you're
talented smith but unfortunately your
blade did not make the cut i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor thank you all for having me
thank you good job sean
i thought that the whole thing was sharp
and i guess i was wrong i'm definitely
gonna go home bust out a bunch of knives
and make sure all those suckers are
sharp as hell
ron congratulations that makes you the
fortune fire champion man and you gotta
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
i'm i'm so proud i would encourage
anyone to come and try this experience
it doesn't matter whether you're new to
blade smithing or you're a seasoned
veteran if i can do it at 50 you can do
it at 25.
you